program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
tonight on politics now roe v wade
overturned a landmark decision by the
supreme court puts abortion rights in
the hands of the states
we're ready to be first and we have the
broad support we need
the push to be first nevada democrats
make their case to the dnc to jump to
the front of the primary line
and under fire federal agents seize the
phone of nevada's gop leader as they
investigate the 2020 election
from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler nearly 50
years of federal abortion rights are
over friday the supreme court ruled in
favor of overturning roe v wade allowing
states to now ban abortions the 6-3
majority ruling was expected it's a case
that came out of mississippi it's the
first time a right first granted by the
supreme court has subsequently been
taken away the ruling is a huge victory
for pro-life groups across the country a
major setback for the pro-choice
movement and protests are expected to
have already been happening nevada's
constitution meanwhile does have
protections for abortions for women
after the supreme court ruling president
joe biden urged voters to take action
it's a realization of an extreme
ideology and a tragic error by the
supreme court in my view
the court has done what it has never
done before
expressly take away a constitutional
right
that is so fundamental
to so many americans that had already
been recognized
the court's decision to do so will have
real and immediate consequences this
extreme and dangerous path the court is
now taking us on
meanwhile nevada's other democratic
leaders in the senate and congress and
across the state released statements
strongly against the verdict that is
governor sysolak you're seeing there
you'll remember last month he released a
statement saying nothing would change
again because abortion protections exist
in nevada's constitution elsewhere
around the country though many states
have already signed laws to outlaw
abortion 26 states are expected to
restrict abortion moving forward
in other political news the push is on
to make nevada first in line to pick a
democratic presidential candidate
officials made their case to the dnc
earlier this week
as a diverse accessible and union strong
battleground state
nevada represents the bright future of
the democratic party we're ready to be
first and we have the broad support we
need to bring historic change to this
primary process
nevada democrats have been pushing to
jump ahead of iowa and new hampshire and
highlight it as you heard there our
state's diversity as one reason why on
july 8 the dnc rules committee will vote
on whether to change the order then a
full vote from the democratic national
committee will come about august 6.
last year the nevada legislature voted
to change from caucuses to primaries
after a lot of folks complained caucuses
just took too long
so this change from the democrats this
would only affect the democratic primary
position
for the choice of a president in 2024
the republican primary is still going to
be fourth for the gop but first in the
west nevada democrats they've been
united in their desire to make nevada
first in the process for choosing a
president clark county commissioner
william mccurdy was part of this week's
presentation
well commissioner you've just gotten
back from washington and you were there
to talk to the dnc and try and
present the case of why nevada should be
first
we've spoken about this with several
other democrats in the state before but
from your point of view again why should
nevada be first in the democratic
primary
well you know uh being first in in the
process matters it matters uh not only
for the state itself but it matters for
the candidates to get really get a
perspective uh from a truly diverse
state uh that truly reflects uh what the
diversity of america looks like um i
think that uh for nevada we not only
have a diversity in our favor but we
also have you know a very easy
uh easily accessible uh geography you
know we have you know over urban and
rural we have two media markets which
you know for you know uh candidates is
very beneficial to them it's low cost
you know and it allows them to get their
message out throughout the entire state
we went up there and we made the case as
to why we should be first and i believe
that uh you know we really did a really
good job you know letting everyone know
just who nevada is what we've done and
what we continue to do in the future if
iowa didn't have the issues that it had
you know a couple of years ago and if
nevada had not changed to being only a
primary
would you would the democrats in nevada
even be in this position right now
uh the goal uh with this is to make sure
uh that the first state to go up truly
reflects the diversity of america as i
said uh nevada looks like america and it
reflects not only our future uh but it
reflects the entire party
and i'm not going to get into you know
other states or you're not going to talk
about iowa although you know there were
some issues there
um i could open the door at least no i
mean you have to acknowledge it and open
the door slightly
it certainly didn't hurt i'm gonna say
that it certainly didn't hurt uh but but
truly uh the goal for us was to just
make sure that we went there and we um
made the case for why nevada should go
first and why we should you know be in
that early spot and why we uh deserve
a strong consideration uh for the first
fight on the calendar
final question is i think
just trying to broaden it out beyond the
pitch that's already been made by
yourself and senator rosen and other
prominent democrats in nevada is
the the goal to make sure that from a
democratic standpoint you have the right
candidate for the presidential race in
2024 but also maybe even beforehand now
activating the base trying to get uh
other members of the democratic party or
uh those who are
nonpartisan
invested now
for the for the races that are happening
now is there is that too big of a
connection to draw it's very reasonable
to say that because of this early
attention because of the
ability for us to connect with
candidates and be able to you know
really um excite the base
that will provide evidence as to you
know how a candidate can do across the
nation coming to nevada you know in that
early window it's been truly beneficial
to us uh that is also why it is
important for us to make the case uh to
to be first uh and we have done well
over time commissioner i appreciate the
time thank you sir appreciate it thank
you so much john
and again a final decision expected in
august
first from our 8 news now i-team fbi
agents have served a search warrant on
nevada's top gop official agents seized
the cell phone of state republican
chairman michael mcdonald it's part of
an investigation into the fake electors
scheme initiated at the end of the 2020
presidential election mcdonald's
attorney has not responded to our
requests for comment we reached out to
him though didn't hear back similar
subpoenas though are reportedly being
served on republican officials in other
states the i-team previously reported
justice department officials are
investigating the scheme to create
alternate electors in multiple
battleground states a scheme from the
republicans nevada gop members sent
phony electoral certificates to the
national archives that matter is
currently being investigated by the
house january 6 committee
republican gubernatorial candidate joey
gilbert is still contesting his primary
loss
gilbert lost to clark county sheriff joe
lombardo however gilbert's campaign
believes the results are inaccurate no
county or state official though has made
a similar claim gilbert has repeatedly
refuted the results of the 2020
presidential election as well
back in washington more public testimony
this week from the house special
committee investigating last year's
capitol hill attack thursday they
focused on former president trump's
effort to pressure his justice
department into action and overturn the
election results basil john reports
he thought the justice department had
not done
enough during the fifth hearing of the
january 6 committee former top doj
officials told the panel former
president donald trump pushed them to
overturn the election it was a brazen
attempt
to use the justice department to advance
the president's personal political
agenda former deputy attorney general
richard donahue said the department of
justice looked at the president's claims
of election fraud were any of the
allegations he brought up found credible
did you find any of them credible
no
donahue and former acting attorney
general jeffrey rosen told the former
president they couldn't change the
election results how did the president
respond to that sir
he responded very quickly and said
essentially
that's not what i'm asking you to do
what i'm just asking you to do is just
say it was corrupt and leave the rest to
me and the republican congressman both
top officials said the president wanted
someone in charge at the doj who would
do what he wanted but neither donahue or
rosen would go along with his wishes the
united states justice department
functions on facts evidence and law and
those are not going to change so you can
have whatever leadership you want
but the department's position is not
going to change evidence also shows
there was an effort by pennsylvania
republican congressman scott perry to
get a new attorney general in position
before january 6. the january 6th
hearings will resume after summer recess
reporting in washington i'm basil john
a nevada state senator wants an audit of
all state spending under governor
sysolak's coronavirus emergency
declaration state senator scott hammond
asked for the audit on tuesday he
represents the centennial hills area
hammond wants an investigation into a
nevada covent testing company news
reports show it collected millions in
state dollars but the tests that it
actually provided were deeply flawed
clark county school district has a lot
on its plate not enough teachers
disputes between trustees and
administrators and hanging over all of
this reorganization back in 2017 a law
was passed up in carson city to
decentralize ccsd and give schools more
control over money and decisions so has
that actually happened and could the
state step in this week i spoke with
mark newbern vice president of nevada's
board of education
the previous state superintendent steve
canavero went through a long process to
get the district
to commit to a set of changes to try to
bring it into compliance
now we're here five years down the road
uh the state board of education and the
superintendent have been petitioned by
principals members of the community and
and teachers union to step in
the
the complaint is that
the
realization has not fully occurred the
local school precincts don't have the
authority that they're supposed to have
and that the district's attempting to
re-centralize the decision on what's
right for students no longer solely
belongs to central office the local
school precincts now have a say in that
and they're supposed to get the
resources to enforce that so the the
battle has been one is it's an immensely
complex dis district so any
reorganization i mean this is the
biggest
uh reform in a generation is going to
take time it's going to be complex
um
the question is the district's heart in
it and you know have they sort of
shortchanged
the precincts
not giving them
the authority of the legislature
intended why are you hesitant to think
that they really want to do this
um
because we don't i don't think they
really want to do this i mean we
i
i think our
or at least my view is that they've
been dragged kicking and screaming sort
of every step of the way
this pulls i mean it's a complex
district
and pulling that sort of decision-making
authority
down to the school precinct certainly
makes
the
the superintendent's job who probably
already has the most difficult job in
the state more complex
and so there's no real advantage to the
central office to do this
except that it's law except that it's
law so if they're not following the law
what what could the state
do well
what we've done recently is we've
enacted some regulations part of the
reason we're five years down the road
and and they're still not in compliance
is there's never been any consequence
and so we've started laying out a set of
actions
that
create a cost for non-compliance
a penalty a penalty so an increasing
steps
of severity to try to to motivate the
district to show them that we don't want
to be here five years from now in the
same exact position this you have to
take this serious there's going to be a
cost going forward you need to engage
with us and work with us so we can
resolve this and at some point
potentially could this state take over
ccsd receivership
there's a provision for receivership now
there's a lot of anger at the district
right now and and so people sort of
heard that and they envisioned us
charging in like the marines and taking
the taking this administrator's building
and and throwing everybody into
reorganization jail but that's not
really what we're talking about we're
talking about the ability to go in for a
receiver to go in
and change
some specific school district
regulations to come into compliance so
it's a very limited receivership
and the process is really designed so
it's very unlikely to happen what we're
attempting to do is
pull authority away from another state
size organization and move it down to to
the school precincts where the
legislature wants that authority and
money to be but hypothetically if
the whole idea of reorganization is that
a local school knows better than the
central office
is by extension the central office
better at knowing about clark county
than the state
in the general case that's true and
that's how we view it but in this case
but in this case we're required
to act in order to enforce the law
clark county school district says it is
following the reorganization law in a
statement to eight news now this week
ccsd says the last couple of compliance
items cannot be satisfied without
bargaining unit agreement and a clear
understanding of the 85 percent funding
requirement to school budgets
ccsd says we remain focused on student
achievement and will continue moving
forward to ensure our students receive a
high level of education
still to come here on politics now gun
control front and center in congress
this week we'll look at the changes
lawmakers are pushing through
about switching to the battle
welcome back to politics now
buffalo uvalde philadelphia tulsa just
some of the cities that have seen mass
shootings in the last month the surge of
these shootings has pushed congress into
action thursday the senate passed its
most far-reaching gun control
legislation in decades even as the
supreme court ruling rolls some
restrictions back hannah brant reports
in a major breakthrough moment congress
is pushing forward a package of gun
legislation this will become the most
significant piece of anti-gun violence
legislation congress has passed in three
decades the package took weeks of
bipartisan negotiation between senators
chris murphy and john cornyn the final
legislation will enhance background
checks fund enforcement of state red
flag laws and expand mental health
resources this bill includes targeted
common sense measures to prevent
violence
and to save lives
while respecting our constitution but
not everyone agrees while 15 senate
republicans voted for the reforms a
majority voted against them including
texas senator ted cruz i agree do
something but do something that works do
something that will stop these crimes
still supporters are celebrating this as
a bipartisan success senator chuck
schumer says democrats will keep
fighting for stronger gun laws but for
now it is a long overdue step in the
right direction just hours before the
senate passed that package the supreme
court struck down a new york gun law the
court ruled that americans have the
right to carry guns in public for
self-defense we're hoping that this is
going to stop the persecution of lawful
and legal gun owners in new york state
instead
of working to protect our communities
this court has made it even easier for
potentially dangerous people to carry
concealed handguns in public spaces in
washington i'm hannah brant
nevada's democratic senate delegation
praised the bipartisan measure in a
statement you see there senator
catherine cortez masto says it will make
real progress to reduce violence and
keep our communities safe senator jackie
rosen also a democrat of course after
decades of inaction in washington and
reducing gun violence including after
the horrific one october shooting she
says the senate has finally broken the
logjam and passed the most significant
breakthrough on gun safety legislation
in nearly 30 years
this week the biden administration
announced plans to suspend the federal
gas tax through the summer however any
change on the federal level will not
affect prices here in nevada there's a
state law here that says if the federal
gas tax changes goes down state taxes
will increase to make up the difference
however the regional transportation
commission is looking into whether it
could lower or suspend the clark county
gas tax
a new bill could make it easier for
families to afford their first mortgage
senator cortez masto helped introduce
some new legislation on this this week
the affordable housing bond enhancement
act aims to improve mortgage revenue and
credit programs could open the door for
thousands of families to refinance their
home and then manage that first mortgage
still to come here on politics now clark
county officially set some rules for
short-term rentals what it means for
communities across southern nevada
and they can be an eyesore during your
commute when will all those political
signs
go away
i'll tell you that i'm
local
now
you're watching politics now
welcome back the nevada supreme court
state supreme court has set new
boundaries on how the state can manage
groundwater in places with severe
drought a priority doctrine typically
grants tenured land owners first rights
over water for water over newer owners
basically if you've already got the land
first you get the water first but this
week's ruling lets areas impacted by
drought deviate from that rule a major
change since so much of nevada is
affected by drought
short-term home rentals airbnbs verbose
for example well now they have a
concrete set of rules to follow an
unincorporated clark county for the
first time they used to be illegal
commissioners this week unanimously
approved new regulations for those
short-term rental properties the rules
among many
no more than 10 people are allowed in
each rental properties must be at least
2500 feet away from a resort and there
must be at least a thousand feet between
the rentals themselves
last year the nevada legislature
approved a state law which requires
counties to allow short-term rentals
commissioners say those rules by the way
might lessen moving forward this is sort
of the first round expect them to change
as it goes forward
all right so the primary election the
primary is over so when are all these
signs going to come down
well candidates who lost last week in
the primary they have 15 days to clean
up their mess
they should be removed by this upcoming
wednesday and if they're not candidates
can be fined
more politics now right after this on 8
news now
[Music]
only at your las vegas area hyundai
dealer
[Music]
welcome back to politics now here's a
look at what to watch in the weeks ahead
of course the major news from washington
d.c continues to be the ruling from the
supreme court overturning roe v wade and
the abortion protections on a federal
level so moving forward we will see how
this will impact first the political
races not only nationwide but across
nevada and what other legal challenges
could come again nevada has this in the
constitution but it's very different
elsewhere in the country we're also
waiting to see if nevada democrats will
get to pick a presidential candidate
first the last big push from the local
dnc is over a preliminary decision is
expected in the next two weeks a final
decision from the democratic national
committee expected in august this for
the 2024 presidential election
that'll do it here on politics now don't
forget all the latest on political news
you can find it at eight newsnow dot com
we're back with you once again next
saturday and as we finish here a look at
the supreme court
home of two major rulings this week
again thank you for watching politics
now we'll see you next time
[Music]